hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm adorable right so adorable rachel is
back at it with me again and she's a
huge Disney fan so I figure who better
to cover the trailer part dose for the
Nutcracker and the four realms have you
seen any of the Nutcracker things
whether it be ballet animated movie my
little puppet show in my bedroom which
one I have seen the ballet actually a
friend of mine was in the official
ballet in Seattle so how do you go see
it I have seen the Care Bears Nutcracker
movie which is not really the Nutcracker
but it likes to pretend it is we used to
listen to the classic kids cassettes
when I was a kid which if anyone
remembers those we listen to the
Tchaikovsky one which covered a lot of
the Nutcracker stuff so I guess that
technically I have all that knowledge
tips before we go into this trailer
though I want to give a page in the day
shout-out to a woman named Natalie Doran
Natalie Doran lives all the way in
higher land that's why I do that
accurate Irish in person that is what a
way this all links Natalie actually just
went to America for the first time went
to Disney World
no this also links Natalie I want you to
know you are constantly cracking my nuts
in all the right ways so I'm so happy to
know you my dear you are as beautiful as
the sunshine on the cracking of John's
nuts I love you I hope this shoutout
will suffice first let's watch the
Nutcracker
this time has been difficult for us Wow
but Christmas comes we were still best
to enjoy anything
Ken's McKenzie boy looks beautiful
working freemen Wow oh it's very rough
huh that's what makes me nervous he was
not clean the Russians or sucks
princess Don Knotts our realms lies with
you be careful who you trust
[Music]
don't destroy everything none of that
right
I'm getting a strong Alice in Wonderland
fire I'm you know don't I'll give an
opinion in three two one yeah Alice in
Wonderland in terms of its aesthetic
however it doesn't feel like it's tone
will be as annoying or corny I kind of I
hope no I guess I'm getting the
impression that this will feel a little
bit more dark a little more wait scope
good yeah because the Nutcracker in and
of itself is actually kind of dark very
dark thing yeah I didn't see any rats
though yeah what's up with that where's
the guys you know you get Morgan Freeman
but you don't get rats what's up what
the hell I think you're the most recent
person in a YouTube video to get excited
to see Morgan Freeman we won't bring up
any of those allegations no let's stick
to just the movie can we just stick to
the fact that he's a wonderful performer
for now yeah we can do that we don't
have to destroy this reputation of the
movie just by us talking about it
briefly it's kind of doing that the guy
who she was writing in the ice carriage
I thought that was Dustin Hoffman for a
second I think the production design
looks very appealing and I liked what
you said during the reaction
I like there's a really a Russian vibe
and because this isn't the Nutcracker
it's bad yeah and so it's a Russian
ballet it's very fitting obviously I
mean it looks gorgeous just like a lot
of these other live-action movies
they've done recently is Helen Mirren a
character that's from the play it
doesn't look like yeah looks like that's
supposed to be the Rat King
yeah that's they seem like they've
really taken some creative liberties
here which is fine
there's people like yourself who I feel
like would have more of an issue with
that then someone like me per se who's
not as passionately drawn to something
like the Nutcracker the Nutcracker is
fine I guess I'm just I've had it a bit
of an issue personally with a lot of
Disney remakes recently because they
just don't feel warranted for existence
yeah I like the idea of taking a new
spin on things but I've just not been
very impressive a lot of the execution
of a lot of those films that's fair so I
don't know that and again watching this
I already don't see a lot of things from
the play
so that makes me nervous I'm seeing
things that are definitely not from the
play so I'm just like what are we doing
to the Nutcracker now why are we trying
to change up everything I don't know
that's my first impression I'm cool with
things getting weird and bizarre which
is what the Nutcracker is in my eyes I
like all the weirdness to it it does
feel Tim burton-esque so that could be a
good thing or a bad thing yeah I know
what's going on the other thing too is
Mackenzie Foy is a talented actress this
could be a big thing for her but I don't
feel like that the trailers are really
showcasing her in a way that makes me
appeal to the mate like right now
they're pitching the world the
environment the designs but I need
something that's more emotionally
investing yeah I mean I'm excited to at
least see her it looks like they cast it
pretty well she's a great actress issues
ever since she was a CGI baby in
Breaking Dawn I let my favorite
franchise of all time me too
really yeah we have this in common I
mean yeah I'm excited to see what she
does she seemed like a little mini Emma
Watson to me but I think I don't know
that's just amazing this trailer I think
that it'll definitely showcase a better
performance cute also is that Keira
Knightley
that is Keira Knightley yeah I mean
that's what these Disney movies do
though is they give you a crazy
production design crazy CGI a wide range
of actors to be in here who are kind of
barely in the movie and maybe one or two
of them stands out yeah I know how these
things go if this can stick to be a
darker kind of really commit to its
weirdness I could be on board for this I
guess I'm kind of worried that the
trailer is not communicating any of its
wacky tone because I imagine that cuz
it's Disney it might go into some wacky
humor territory a wriggle and time
didn't really do that but this is a
different kind of property so I'm kind
of thinking there's probably gonna be
some wacky humor in here I'm not sure
yeah I know that kind of makes me
nervous too and again I just from what
I'm seeing I'm a little nervous but I
always still like to give movies the
benefit of the doubt yeah I'm looking
forward to seeing what this movie has to
offer
trailers are not to have cover songs in
there and this just a girl cover I think
fits for it yeah I want to know more
about Mackenzie boys Clara a ballet is
one thing but if you're gonna do a movie
you know I kind of like and I'm
interested to see what they do with this
I like that the movie also
has a bit of a circus vibe to it yeah as
it should yeah I think that's a that's a
great thing to go for like I said weird
absurd things it's a beautiful looking
film Kenzi Foy is a wonderful actress
and there's a whole bunch of actors in
here I'm sure this film will be if not
great it'll be passable by the way is
that guy that she was talking to
supposed to be the Nutcracker where's
the Nutcracker the black guy yeah I
don't know cool diversity I guess yeah
Abbot IDing Disney unless that's a
nutcracker might be yeah we're a king
and who was the defining Nutcracker
maybe she's a nutcracker just like how
my wife is going to kiss Aurora anyway
guys are you excited for the Nutcracker
in the four realms I'm sure you're
moderately looking forward to this you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell because hey
subscribe button suck and check us on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is a music video coverage you
have a channel I do I was on that
channel one your word that's right you
were on it you have an existing channel
adorkable Rachel three times we shot
like 18 videos videos maybe it was 18 I
don't remember twist followed dorable
[Laughter]
rag1 channels trust me on it good day
see ya